please give a warm welcome to joey coco
diaz
[Applause]
keep it going for these two guys one
more time what's happening you bad
[__] thank you for coming out
tonight
i appreciate it friday night dc
you got [__] to do you got [__] to do
[__]
[__] it i love this town it's very nice
very clean but i've been here three days
i have not seen a [__] [__] yet you
understand me
everybody's trying to be [__]
sensitive all of a sudden oh my god i
love
[__]
three [__] days i haven't seen the
[__] everybody cares about ten years
ago nobody gave a [__]
about a [__] [__] all right you see
one of them on the corner
like [__] that trailer let's get out of
here
now everybody gives a [__] about the
[__] oh he's a hero okay
look at this [__] adam's apple see
how much of a hero he is
[__] hero you got your [__] words
[__] up there hero
i'm supposed to feel like oh and i get
it listen i get it man
i feel sensitive sometimes i got
estrogen running through my [__] body
look at my titties i'm alive and kicking
you understand me
you know sometimes i feel womanly i put
on barbra streisand i smoke a joint
i feel my nuts and i'm back you
understand me
you never want to switch governments
you hold on to that dick you understand
me you
never give up the dick i don't give a
[__] who shows up
take the kid take my wife you ain't
taking my dick [__]
give a [__] jack
you feel womanly tuck the dick between
your legs like the guy from [__]
silence or lambs remember
he was all creeped out with the [__]
cape on and [__]
telling the chubby chick to rub oil on
at that one
do that [__] in the morning he takes out
pops it the [__] out
and don't be looking at me like this
weird guys you've all put your dick
between your legs at one part of your
life or another
all right when you come out of the
shower you tuck it in there you're like
oh i got a hot [__]
i gotta shave my stomach and go to the
donut shop
the [__] in l.a hang out at a donut
shop i don't know what they do here i
don't know
a lot of he's like joey what the [__]
let me tell you something all right
i mean let's dig deep here for a minute
we're family we're here on a friday
night together right
listen the first time you saw that
picture of katelyn
what's the first thing that really came
to your mind okay
you're like what the [__] is this what
the [__] is this [__]
but then you caught yourself your logic
and society's rules
because you can't walk at the start box
and say [__] caitlyn what the [__] is
that
those gentiles are run out of there like
a milano oh my god
we're gluten free oh you can't say [__]
about me i might disintegrate
your [__] momos hanging out at
starbucks
weakening our [__] nation you don't
put milk in your coffee [__]
it's black black with sugar not splenda
none of that [__]
it's black [__] coffee you don't know
this i'm gonna skinny frappuccino
like what the [__] are you talking about
god forbid you're going to your little
job with your starbucks cups
and your [__] folk friends won't
[__] see you black coffee 7-eleven
[__]
the [__] isis drinks and [__] that's why
they're taking it to the next level
they even stop cutting heads off now
because they drink that [__]
brazilian bowl that [__] will keep you
up
for [__] days chopping heads off and
[__]
[__] starbucks that ass water
eight dollars for [__] coffee
sorry i got emotional about coffee
[__] transvestites i got